welcome to the Michaela Peterson podcast
this is episode 77. this is my very
favorite format of episode opposing
views you hear views from both sides of
contentious issues and you can make your
own mind up and this is an episode on
covid everything covid vaccines
passports the great reset it's intense
big news I was just remonetized so
hopefully this episode doesn't
immediately get me demonetized again
I emailed 20 doctors to get views from
the mainstream medical community on
covet just like the normal people views
everyone said no except one guy one a
virologist so when you're listening to
the following conversations remember
this was the only guy that would agree
to be on this episode so kudos to him
first you're going to hear from Dr Joe
Mercola he's an alternative medical
practitioner and he's recently released
a book called The Truth About covid-19
exposing the great reset lockdowns
vaccine passports and The New Normal
that's linked below
he has what's seen by the mainstream
media as the more conspiratorial view on
covid and vaccines the great reset Etc
the second half of this episode is with
Dr Jeremy Camille he's a virologist and
holds the more popular mainstream view
of covid he did his post-doctoral
fellowships at Cornell University in
Harvard Medical School and currently
works at Louisiana State University let
me know what you guys think about this
episode please try to be polite this is
a super contentious subject and finding
guests was nearly impossible please
don't bully anyone or these episodes
will be even harder for me to set up
be good remember to hit subscribe if you
enjoy this content
this episode is brought to you by
self-authoring self-authoring was
developed by my dad over the last 30
years with help from two other phds at
Mcgill and Harvard
it has past authoring allowing you to
write out your past great for trying to
work through trauma I'd recommend
writing about trauma at minimum a year
after it's gone so you don't
re-traumatize yourself
it has present authoring which helps you
write out your present identify flaws
that you can work on figuring out and
future authoring which helps you make a
plan for the future with code MP you get
10 off at self-authoring.com and it's a
great thing for people who are trying to
organize themselves I really believe in
it if you don't have a goal you have
nothing to aim for this helps fix that
that code also works at
understandmyself.com if you want to
check out your personality using a valid
personality scale enjoy this episode
[Music]
thank you
Dr Mercola welcome to my podcast well
such a pleasure Michaela thanks for
everything you're doing and helping
promote Health and Wellness in this area
in this world because there's so many
people who don't get it and they need
the truth and knowledge so I really I
deeply appreciate your passion and your
commitment to helping people understand
Health at a deep level
thank you thank you very much uh for for
anybody who doesn't know you can you
give a brief background about who you
are and what it is you do
well I'm a formerly trained physician
for the since 1982 is when I graduated
from nearly 40 years now and um
my foot my specialty is family medicine
I've treated tens of thousands of
patients before I formally shifted out
into well I shifted into natural
medicine in the early 90s and then was
able to help lots of people and then I
am also a passionate about tech so I
started in Tech in the late 60s with my
first computer programming class and it
was an early adopter of the internet
like the mid 90s and it actually started
my own website in 97 which is years
before Google and then hopefully will
become an important Point later in our
conversation but uh sorry predated
Google
and
um I've had the most visited Natural
Health site in the world for the last 17
years is B I think it might the
statistics might be changed it's really
hard to know now because of the
bastardization of the whole system and
and how you actually categorize and the
information started to get now in the
Google is censoring essentially any
Natural Health site so it's a confusing
State of Affairs to say the least so we
don't really have accurate metrics now
but for the longest time we did I was
the most and I've got many New York time
best-selling books and and I got a new
one coming out now which is why we're
talking this is going to be another best
seller because Amazon has already
pre-ordered a hundred thousand copies of
this book
they rarely rarely do that it's probably
only a handful of books that they do
this in a year so when it's coming out
at the end of April it's called the
truth about covid-19 and hopefully we're
going to touch on some of those things
today
I'm so excited to do this I found out
about you a long time ago uh when I was
trying to figure out what was going on
with my health and I went through your
website and I read some of your kind of
science articles that are broken down so
anybody can read them and I thought okay
some of this makes sense and then I did
a background search on you on Google and
you came up under quack watch and I was
like ah [ __ ] this is just one of those
guys that's selling supplements and
taking advantage of sick people
um because I'd been to a whole bunch of
naturopaths before and my mom had spent
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
dollars on tests and supplements and
nothing had ever done anything because I
was so sick
so I totally brushed you off
that was when I think I was like 18.
I did I did you know like five years of
research and tried to figure out what
was going on and when I was 24 I was
like are you kidding me
this guy actually knows what he's doing
that's crazy but you are very much on
the Alternative Health Spectrum like I
would say if there's an if there's a
spectrum and
you know microbiome experts are over
here you and and mainstream medicine is
like way out of the frame you're you're
you're almost out of the frame over here
I don't like to view it as alternative
because this really is the traditional
medicine is the medicine that our
ancient ancestors use and many still
ancient cultures still incorporate so we
just I I choose to believe that although
conventional medicine which is modern
medicine typically uh with antibiotics
and surgery I mean it can it's really
really useful for some limited
indications like mostly acute traumas uh
and you if you get in a car accident
you're going to want to go to a Trauma
Center you're not going to want to see a
natural medicine doctor until afterward
and you recover from it but uh there's
indications for it but those indications
are pretty limited probably far less
than five percent of the health
challenges that we encounter today
yeah my um my decision for going to a
doctor uh is usually because I need some
sort of surgery right yeah that's the
that's my rule right now or if I pick up
a serious infection
yeah but in your case specifically my
heart bleeds for you because I've
treated thousands of patients with
rheumatoid arthritis and a few with JRA
like you have uh and and that was one of
my first entries into natural medicine
and um
so if you would need surgery for a joint
correction from the JRA that's not
really treating the problem that's
treating the symptom you know it's a so
they're never really hardly ever
addressing the cause of why you got the
remote arthritis in the first place and
we've had an offline conversation about
different things that you do and I just
commend you for your
it's so rare to find an individual like
you who just is so committed and
knowledgeable to searching for the truth
you are way less than five percent of
the population probably way less than
one percent you know I know me to put
you on a pedestal but you got to
recognize that you have a rare trait and
I it and hopefully people will
understand this and be inspired by your
actions to know they too have the power
to what we use as our Mantra is to take
control of your health which is what the
primary focus of what we're seeking to
share with individuals is they can do it
they don't need to rely on the
conventional medical system they can do
copy exactly your behavior and figure it
out for themselves and hopefully where
there is a resource to help catalyze and
speed up that learning curve yes exactly
okay let's start off
by covering covid and the great reset
which I really don't know much about so
let's start I think I think let's start
with covet and get into that so is covid
a flu
well no it's not a flu it's clearly not
a flu I mean there's a lot of uh
controversy on this issue there's a
significant segment I believe in the
National medicine Community or another
Health Community that believes it's not
even a virus that it's just a Terrain
problem and I have problems with that
because there is clearly an infectious
disease I mean there's just no question
in my mind it is and to to argue that
it's not is just putting people down a
wrong unnecessary tangent because
they're missing the big bigger picture
so it's it it I think there's more than
enough evidence to suggest it's an
infectious disease it's a coronavirus as
everyone knows
now that not of the flu is actually is
influenza virus so it's a different
virus now the coronavirus can cause cold
like symptoms which is similar to the to
the flu but it's clearly a bit different
so it's a and there's other more serious
illnesses like MERS Middle Eastern
respiratory virus and some other SARS
Cub one that our previous serious
coronavirus infections but for the most
part it's it's a it's a relative it's a
what they call a novel coronavirus a
novel means new so it didn't really
exist before 2019 this variant of a
coronavirus so it's its own unique
system so it's clearly clearly appears
to be an infectious disease a new one
not previously identified there's other
entire controversy whether this was uh a
natural outcome of breeding this in bats
or it was leaked from a lab and I think
there's beyond beyond compelling
evidence now this coming I mean emerging
and we documented this in February of
2020 that it really was engineered in
lab that this is a no
yes this is get there's no there's no
that's a big part of the discussion of
the book there there's gain of function
research that was that was being
performed in the Wuhan lab which is it's
a there is a specific labs and there's
China only has a few we have hundreds in
the United States of the they're called
BSL biosafe biosafety levels yes I might
be missing one of the letters and bio
safety levels Labs I'm missing one
letter I forget what it is but they
they're level four Labs which is the
highest level that of isolation and so
that they don't get contaminated uh but
appears to be in engineered created from
scratch or almost or or take they've
taken a break an existing coronavirus
and and introduced functions in it that
make it more more deadly and infectious
so there's it's not clear at all if it
was accidentally released or
intentionally released and I don't make
any uh claims of to either but it does
appear to there's just such strong
evidence we don't have time to go into
it we can literally discuss it for three
hours and it's very compelling I've
written about it on my site I mean you
can get deep down into the weeds and the
hardcore science and electrical
biological level to show that it it
clearly was engineered
wow okay okay I'm we're not going to get
into it but like a little bit into it
why would were they would they have just
been well like why I mean the US has
funded this it's a tune of millions of
dollars file she funded it uh and then
and and not just last year I mean the
research has been gone for a long time
the University of North Carolina Ralph
Barrick is a is a big coronavirus or
coronavirus uh researcher so the
question is to why and this is the
justification and the excuse they give
is that well if someone else does it
then we have to be prepared to defend
ourselves so it's a defensive strategy
is the nuclear war type of thing yeah so
and but in the meantime it's actually a
form of BioWare by a Warfare and I've
interviewed twice now Francis Boyle who
is a uh I think he might be a professor
emeritus at the University of Illinois
and he's actually responsible for one of
the major treaties he I think he drafted
that in the late 80s that would actually
if if someone is convicted of uh this by
engaging in BIO Warfare activities they
have a lifetime imprisonment I mean
there's no he he he's sort of a pacifist
we excluded the death sentence in this
but it's definitely lifetime
imprisonment and I think many of these
people should be in prison lifetime for
what they're doing
it's just it's it's bio Warfare It's
what they're what they're creating and
that's that's against the law attorneys
that have been signed by virtually every
country on the planet
wow okay I wasn't expecting that no I
wasn't expecting that well it's not it's
it's kind of an interesting tangent and
it you know it's not the big part of the
story that's a relatively minor Smart in
the story there's there's much more
points that I want people to understand
before we finish the conversation that's
that's like okay that's nice but that's
not the real deal there's there's much
uh more points you need to take home
before we leave but plus it wouldn't
really matter right because it's already
out yeah it's already out it doesn't
matter and there's going to be another
one I mean there's they're very clear
the I don't know are you familiar with
event 201 or 210 no 201 was no okay so
event 201 was held at Johns Hopkins in
Maryland Baltimore
uh six to eight weeks before covet 19.
six to eight weeks and what was it well
it was John Hopkins it was the world
economic Forum it was the Melinda Gates
Foundation and they all got together and
they had this trial run this exercise
what would happen if we got infected
with coronavirus infection and they ran
through the newscast and all the things
that they wanted to do and they it was a
trial run for covert 19. that's totally
traveling they knew it was coming they
absolutely knew it was coming otherwise
why would they do it eight weeks before
so this is their pattern they they
broadcast what they're doing they let
the world know
but not everyone knows even people like
you did who were pretty sharped and
didn't know that they did that so it's
they they leave these Clues all around
so they're they're gonna there's gonna
be another one now whether it's an
infectious or bioterrorism act it's this
is the strategy they're using that's
part of the larger picture which is
essentially so you know I'm sure your
primary question is why are they doing
this why could they possibly want to do
this right would that be good how come
people don't know like if it was it well
I don't know I'll give it to the why
they don't know that's a great question
okay okay a lot more complex answer why
is the important one to understand what
is the motivation why would they want to
do this it's very simple and it's part
of the Great recess which is part of the
world economic Forum which sponsors
Davos and as Kosh Schwab is the the guy
you may have heard about the guy looks
like I'm James Bond villain and he
probably is uh but they they've ever
seen him you ever see claw Schwab I'm
telling you tell me he doesn't look like
a James Bond yeah you we should you
should like integrate a picture of him I
will I will yeah you should like gold
figure whoever maybe that's the wrong
one but he does look like a James Bond
film yeah I told you it was pretty crazy
so
yeah so the uh anyway their motivation
and really is part of the Great reset is
this this move towards technocratic
Global tyranny whose primary purpose is
to transfer the vast majority of the
wealth and the assets from everyone else
to them
it's a wealth transfer move is what it
is
and they're you know it's an exercise in
implementing that strategy and the how
they did it is a is a much more complex
analysis and understanding and requires
you know a lot of background to
understand it but essentially that's why
why it's been done and it's very clear
and and if you look at their literature
I mean they've got their videos and
everything they let you know they're not
like hiding the fact it's this it's in
plain sight they're not trying to hide
it
and so that's what your book is about
does it just point out where all these
like hidden secrets are
well they're not hidden it's really in
plain sight it's just that people aren't
aware of it and they couldn't they don't
even believe it so why are they looking
for it and if Martin told something
completely well here that's that's the
key element told something how are we
told something right that's that's the
key question we're told something
typically and in most cases through the
conventional mainstream media
okay so Gates is another player in here
the the
that I failed to mention well I did
mention it was a bill Melinda Case
Foundation but what I did mention is the
World Health Organization is the it's
the really the the tool and the resource
that was was used to implement this
Global shutdown and this catastrophe
that they just did in this last year
so
it kind of because it's a attained the
status of this recognized Global
Authority right so you got to wonder
who's behind the World Health
Organization
Trump and and I don't take a political
stance I'm a pro-trump or anti-trump at
all I'm neutral okay because it's not
about politics but Trump
I think rightly shut down the funding of
the United States from the World Health
organizational last year I don't know if
you know that but he did he shut it down
so when he did that the United States
was the primary funder of the World
Health Organization or who for short
and when they when Trump shut the
support down guess who was the biggest
funder of of the World Health
Organization in the world the biggest
funder Gates yeah skates Bill Gates more
than any other country he was the number
one and he's very strategic Bill Gates
is a very very smart guy highly
strategic but he's part of the global
tyranny effort no question about it and
he over a decade ago embedded himself in
the World Health Organization and
essentially now I mean for the last
decade he's been making himself like a
vital part of the whole process so that
he can implement this strategy with his
which is this vaccine solution and
because that's the only thing that works
and you'd probably kind of think about
this
if you know and we can go into vaccine I
mean I'm not an expert on it and I
haven't studied it deeply but I know
that I can know the broad Strokes
so if you believe that people who are
promoting and supporting this vaccine
are authentic and sincere and and
critically believe that it's going to
end this pandemic
then why and we're getting into some of
these other questions that you had
earlier then you would think they would
allow free discussion of the pros and
cons because there is no way in the
world it is physically impossible that
you could give an informed consent to
any therapeutic intervention unless you
know both sides if you're only told one
side how could it be informed consent it
can't be it's impossible it's it's
essentially propaganda and that's what
they've done
I think so yeah like I an alternative
could be that the people who are in
charge who truly believe the vaccine is
the answer believe that the general
public are too stupid to make their own
decisions and therefore aren't letting
them make their own decisions
because they're doing it for the greater
good and they're right that could be
their
my guess is that's what they tell
themselves that's their justification
but if you like if you go higher and you
look at it objectively and it's hard to
look at this objectively because you
know there's so much emotion about
but if you look at objectively
you have to realize that you to it is as
I said it's impossible to have an
informed consent unless you understand
both sides and they're totally
suppressed it anything anything that
even comes close to hinting of casting
the disparaging vaccines and disparaging
light is immediately removed immediately
censored entirely whole platforms of all
many sites have been taking down
including Bobby Kennedy's who's a you
know he's pretty much vaccine neutral I
mean even though he appears to be an
anti-vaxx person he's if they work fine
he he's vaccinated his family he's not
opposed to them but that you've got to
do with common sense because these
companies these corporations these
multinational corporations that are
making these vaccines like Pfizer being
the classic example and Johnson and
Johnson they're criminal entities
they've been they've been convicted
of crimes in the past paid billions and
billions of dollars in fines for
breaking the law
so why would anyone seriously consider
trusting these companies when they have
a history and the history isn't good
I mean tens of billions of dollars in
fines have been paid by these companies
because they're they're criminals so you
know they've got a track record and the
track record isn't good
but
you know the fact that they're censoring
everything is is really a clue that you
know it it is part of the issue so the
world health reasons you get back to
that
anything that countered the vaccine is
the final solution was censored that
goes down and this is this is if you
just step back get detached and try to
be as objective and non-emotional as you
can you have to understand that there's
the way a vaccine works the way any
intervention works is through your own
immune system and you deeply appreciate
and understand that it's your immune
system that does the work it's not a
magic pill or magic shot that just
catalyzes your own and activates your
own immune process so that you can
effectively defeat these pathogens
so but nothing nothing was done to
address the our own healthy immune
system so any therapeutic intervention
that was suggested as GP and useful was
censored taken off immediately what are
some of the primary examples like
vitamin D I mean we have been exposed to
the sun ever since humans have been
walking the planet it's part of our
natural system to optimize our health
and sadly our vitamin D levels have just
dropped dramatically largely because
most of us live inside and many of us
don't even live in climates that we even
if we didn't live inside or not go you
know we don't even have access to that
amount of sufficient amount of sunlight
to optimize our vitamin D level so
taking a supplement I I sell supplements
but you can absolutely be incredibly
healthy without ever taking these
supplements especially if you're wise
enough to follow carnivore like you
recommend because there's there's such a
nutrient dense diet that that there's
not a lot of supplements you're going to
need with that you know not many maybe
vitamin C but you know not much because
especially if you're eating organ meat
is full of full of almost every mineral
you can get
so anyway they squashed all the vitamin
D information they squashed anything
that that was natural and not only they
scratch the Natural Therapy and by the
way I've neglected to mention that I
published a peer-reviewed a study that
was a review of most all the literature
that was published prior to Summer of
2020 and it was published in a very
prestigious Journal called nutrients and
I had two other co-authors and and it
was peer reviewed and it was published
and it was October of 2020. so that was
the first article I published this
Century I published like 20 the last
century but maybe 25. but you know I
just stopped doing it because I had the
website but I felt this is important
enough to do and we actually have a
um I created another website called stop
covidcold.com
stopcoveredcoal.com free website it's
there's no you don't collect your email
or anything it just has you can download
PDFs you can take a quiz to see how
likely you are to get it so they don't
understand vitamin D and they don't even
believe see that they acknowledge it if
you're obese
that you're at higher risk I mean how
could they not deny that it's just as
the evidence as clear as can be and they
have these other comorbidities which are
like high blood pressure or
diabetes but the the central common
denominator throughout all those
diseases is the fact that they are
insulin resistance and another term for
insulin resistance as you well know is
called metabolic flexibility where your
body has the ability to seamlessly
transition between carbohydrates and
fats as your primary Fuel and most
people in the United States
how many people what percentage
population is metabolically flexible do
you think you probably know this because
you're pretty sure I I don't think I I
do know I'd say 30 20. okay yeah that
that's an interesting and pretty good uh
answer for someone who's a smart issue
but the actual answer is even more
surprising it's only ten percent
so even though obesity what's the
obesity rate the obesity rate well the
obesity rate is about 40 depending what
state you're in
um but or being overweight is about
something yeah so of being overrated is
one characteristic of someone's
metabolically inflexible the other thing
would be diabetes or high blood pressure
uh waist size you know that's abnormal
so
um but it's about 90 of users or you
know triglycerated HDI show there's a
number of clinical variables that you
can use to make that assessment but it's
about close to 90 90 and those were
actually stats from 2016 which was the
ending yeah so wow so there's you know
and that's that's at the core that is
the absolute core of why people are
succumbing to this disease because
they're metabolically and flexible under
vitamin D insufficient but even if you
wanted to take it a level above and you
guys stay within the conventional
medical Paradigm and use drugs which I'm
not a big fan of and use drugs to treat
this disease there were two drugs that
were absolutely vilified even though
they've been used for ages and are
incredibly safe you probably know what
those are hydroxychloroquine and
Ivermectin
hydroxychloroquine
used at the right dose and with zinc
early in the disease is highly highly
effective do I recommend it no I think
there's better strategies but if you're
going to go in conventional medicine you
want to do it's great oh the other thing
they Abilify to is high-dose vitamin C
even though there's many experts within
the conventional medical community
they're experts in emergency medical
care and you know well-respected
professors at universities that uh Paul
Merrick m-a-r-i-k is a one that comes to
mind and he's published this sepsis
protocol which incorporates intravenous
vitamin C thiamin vitamin B1 he's got
the math protocol and that's uh the m is
methylprednisolone which is a steroid uh
and the t is Simon vitamin B1 and the H
is heparin because one of the
symptoms of coping 19 is this clotting
defecting disorder that causes clots to
occur so if the Heparin is an
anti-clouding factor and that kind of
helps the body beds I think there's
better strategies
for sepsis yeah and covid-19 the same
sepsis protocol which is is
I forget the specific number and I'm
sorry I didn't review this earlier but
it's a large number of people I think it
might be hundreds of thousand people a
year die from sepsis there's a large
number of people
but this IV protocol with the vitamin C
is highly effective I mean it's like an
80 effective rate very few interventions
are
100 although the nebulized peroxide 170
000 Americans die as a lot of sepsis per
year well thank you I wasn't too far off
and I wanted to go conservative rather
than look hyperbolic you know so it's
270 000 I was off but I missed it by
seventy thousand that's a lot of people
that's a lot of people yeah
let me just comment on the number if
it's truly 270 000 and it probably is
there's no reason to doubt that
my guess this is so interesting my guess
is that number exceeds the number of
people who died from covid no no you're
wrong 500 000 people die from covid
no did they or did they not
how did they diagnose that covet death
this is another thing we discussed in
the book they used a test typically
the PCR test polymerase Chain Reaction
which is a test that's designed to
amplify or increase in a cycle the
amount of material that they can use to
analyze so typically and every time it's
a cycle they call a cycle threshold so
the number of amplifications ideally
should be about 25 maybe 30 but they
were doing cycle implications of 40. so
what's the consequence of doing a real
high cycle threshold of a PCR test
you're going to get
massively increase your false positives
so they're using a test that was
essentially bastardized and never used
the way it was designed to and they
falsely diagnosed people as being
positive when they weren't
that's the first mistake
and it was facilitated by the World
Health person they allowed it they even
though they knew better than that they
subsequently reduced the cycle threshold
rate as soon as Biden got inaugurated
they actually did on January 6 and if
you can believe it
so they ratcheted it down right
but even assuming that that rate was
okay
I mean not the top right the test was
okay
and then truly there were 500 000 people
who had more positive codes and died
they changed the definition of the on
the death certificate so that if you you
had coveted 19
and you essentially died from anything
including a motorcycle accident
or you had terminal cancer and then
cover 19. your death was covered 19. 100
why did they do that that's because
that's weird even for people who don't
believe these these they did that I can
I'm highly confident I challenge anyone
to dispute that that statement because
it's true there's no question about it
and if you doubt that just look at these
numbers compare the total amount of
deaths
in 2019
to 2020
if in fact 500 000 additional people
died from covid we'd have an increase of
500 000 deaths how many additional
deaths we have in 2020
zero zero zero Michaela
no difference all they did was
reclassify those deaths
they reclassified did they did they
reclassify flu deaths because there are
zero cases of fluids that makes no sense
Nero absolutely every year 40 50 80 000
people die from flu no deaths in 2020.
no deaths from flu because they all died
yeah
no no no it's not because of next it's
because they missed they misplacify them
there were flu deaths of course there
was no reason to believe that there
weren't any flu deaths
I mean it just somehow magically flew
disappeared and covert replace it yeah
right that this is totally irrational
Viewpoint no no there was Zero flu
deaths so
I I think or if it wasn't zero was close
to zero
it was close to the I think it was I
like I read somewhere on a government
website that it was zero and it was
somewhere in Canada
yeah they just changed things it's just
crazy so but it's all to support you
know we got to go back to what we talked
about earlier what is their goal why are
they doing this
I mean because it I mean even previously
there's no government in the world who
could have gotta go away with this you
know there just isn't they don't have
the power the autonomy to do it but they
they use the justification of emergency
orders and that's a big challenge
there's a lot of legal challenges going
out because you know these governors of
these States declare emergency orders
and essentially have they're a total
dictator and autocrat they can do
whatever they want under justification
from its emergency order they elect
people in their houses they're into
prisons which is never ever been done
before in the history of the world to
lock in healthy people it was only used
previously for people who were sick
they never locked in people who weren't
sick
but that's what and you don't you don't
think it's possible like my inclination
is to believe that most people are good
although I have come across some people
who are not good and that people are
scared and stupid and that this is what
happens when masses are being run by
stupid scared people
well I think that's true for the
majority of the population I would tend
to agree with that but you know it's a
bit too too uh it's too weird no no it's
the derogatory Acclaim because I think
people are they want to do well but they
do they just know the time after energy
to understand or the desire to go deep
like you do
and as a result there's a highly
susceptible to propaganda and
brainwashing it's a very effective
strategy a very highly effective
strategy and we didn't touch on this yet
but the whole issue is that well how are
they figuring this thing out well one of
the biggest enemies in this that is this
stealth enemy that hardly anyone
appreciates or understands is Google
they are they are top on the list of
technocrats they blank that because this
is going on YouTube is bleeple
people well I don't know that they're
that that was a joke
but yeah I don't know if that YouTube
might censor this thing I wouldn't be
surprised but anyway I've already
demonetized it's fine yeah well they
made the platform you which is even
worse you know you're not doing you lost
your YouTube channel so you can it's
nice to have YouTube channel because it
has such a wide range and that's going
to change in the future but anyway
Google started as I said after my site
did and then when they first started
they were great I don't know if you were
online back in the late 1990s but they
were they were a miracle when because
all the other surgeons who were trash
and they were really really good and
they did you know they've been they just
progressively became more nefarious and
essentially they had to monetize their
site so they became very very good at
some developing the ability to predict
human behavior and the first way they
did this was Google AdWords so they
could through all the data they were
collecting they knew what was going to
work and what didn't because they had
various sophisticated methods of
analyzing and sophisticated computer
systems
and they could accurately predict you
know really really well what people
would click on what they wouldn't click
on so as a result of that predictive
Behavior they made a lot of money a lot
of money
and they they kind of had to because
they were just providing all the service
they needed a source of Revenue and that
was their way to do it but then they
just extended it and extended it and
they started capturing more and more
data to the point like they themed
between them and Facebook they probably
captured the vast majority of
data that's captured and people use
their magnificent Services they do
provide a lot of value but they do it at
a price because people are surrendering
all their personal data without any idea
that that's what they're doing that's
the price they're paying for using these
services
and so Google's collecting all this
information they know with a very
precise certainty exactly what triggers
will be required to change human
behavior and it's this information
that's shared with the mainstream media
because the mainstream media is
controlled by usually a few entities
that's all it takes and Gates is one of
those entities
he's very cleverly invested significant
sums of money which is relatively small
compared to his net worth but I mean
this probably hundreds of millions maybe
even less
to like the BBC and you know really big
media platforms and so there they would
never publish anything uh that's
negative about Gates they just wouldn't
and they'll only publish things to
support his position and then uh
cooperate in the in their efforts to
censor and de-platform any any opposing
views so they've got to control the
media and they and they know exactly the
stories to run and the information to to
support because they've gathered the
data they know and and typically the the
data they've gathered is to support
the creation of the most powerful
emotion that drives human behavior do
you know what that emotion is
fear yeah you guessed it you nailed it
on the head it's exactly what it is it's
fear and they drive they drove that to
the core they knew it precisely
what story to tell
so effectively
that the vast majority
more than half of the population it's
clamoring for the vaccine they want it
and there's another very effective
strategy that's that any any skilled
marketer would know you know what that
strategy is
something called scarcity
if you make something that you know we
have there's a lot of propaganda behind
it so it's going to solve the solution
it's going to make you immune and you
make it unavailable except to a few
people
you're going to want it because you
can't get it you can't get it right
and that's what they did for three
months very few people get this vaccine
but that's what it was only three months
and that's a relatively small amount of
time 12 weeks right now anyone can get
it
but they created this scarcity so you
were so lucky if you were able to get it
so everyone was clamoring to get this
vaccine and they only had one-sided
story no one told them about the
downsides or the potential downsides
you know what one of the biggest
potential downsides is
what what do you think
of the vaccine
well my concern for a vaccine that
wouldn't be tested for very long would
be infertility okay that's definitely
happened I can tell you a very specific
mechanism how that likely occurs but
what's even a bigger potential downside
especially for someone like you as young
and healthy probably want to brace a
family but no it's death they die okay
you
think that's worse yeah so
if someone's going to die from the
vaccine how will we know
I mean there's been some celebrities who
we know died from the vaccine like Hank
Aaron and there was uh I forget his name
but a very famous boxer who died like
within hours of getting the vaccine but
it's all denied it was all hushed up and
you know covered over but
there are there's a there's a vaccine
registry called theirs the Bears
database
that is voluntary reporting it is and as
a result of the fact that it's voluntary
we know many studies of Madonna says
that the amount of vaccine adverse
reactions that are actually reported are
about one percent of the actual number
okay one percent
so
how many deaths from vaccines if we had
this year
in the various database you wouldn't
know I'll tell you
over two thousand maybe twenty five
hundred
that doesn't sound like a lot
but
let me tell you what it is
first of all if you just look at that
absolute number
it's more deaths
vaccine deaths in the first three months
of 2021 then the last 10 years combined
last 10 years combined
and I already told you it's one percent
so two thousand twenty five hundred
it's a quarter million people
a quarter million people and it's first
three months that's it
one percent
no one percent were reported
so that means 99 were not reported so
the true number is a hundred times two
thousand or two thousand five hundred
gotcha so now do we know that to for
searching no it's just a guess it's a
but we know the numbers are a lot larger
than reports so maybe it's a hundred
thousand but it's still only three
months and they won't they've only given
what 50 million shots and they're
probably going to Triple A or quadruple
it and and deaths continue to occur so
these are just people who dropping dead
in the first few weeks right
um so my guess is that the vaccines will
kill more people than coping 19.
which is not hard to do because remember
500 000 people died well I already
explained earlier that it's a small
fraction of that who actually died from
cover 19. a small fraction so we may
have already exceeded the the cover
deaths right now
that would be horrifying okay let me get
to a few questions okay sure
um
what is an mRNA vaccine and have we had
any other mRNA vaccines great question
had better tests on or longer tests on
do you know what mRNA mRNA is would let
me explain I do but you should explain
anyway so mRNA is messenger RNA it's a
complementary component to DNA uh and
it's kind of like the reverse side of it
and it's created from DNA typically and
it's used to
send a signal it's kind of like the
blueprint that it gives to your protein
Machinery creating Machinery which is
Transfer RNA to create these protein
structures typically from amino acids
so in the case of the messenger RNA
covid-19 vaccines they created a copy or
a blueprint to create the spike protein
of the cover 19. which appears to be the
most immunogenic portion of the of the
coronavirus that would tend to provide
immunity uh it's this message there's
important thing to know about messenger
RNA it's very very fragile
which is why I'm sure you've heard and
most everyone has that they have to be
most of the fact the first two vaccines
had to be kept very cold I mean like
like liquid nitrogen cold I mean way
below anything you can do with a
commercial freezer
regular one that you'd have in your home
so that's way too warm for it so it's
very perishable and they had to protect
it with the liposome which is a fat
droplet that surrounds the messenger RNA
so that it can be protected until it
gets into the body
um so that liposome actually
allows it to not be digested by you
enzymes in your body which essentially
degrade messenger RNA pretty quickly
because it doesn't stick around very
long does it does its jobs and your body
gets rid of it but in the liposome it
could last a lot longer and Jody
mikovitz is a PhD molecular biologist
nephrologist I suspect you've heard of
her before she's quite controversial and
but she's really smart woman on this and
she believes that these messenger RNA
liposomes can get into body tissues and
last for a long long time so what does
that mean if she's right
and we don't know I mean yeah so you've
got you've got a a signal a blueprint
telling your body to make this Spike
protein continuously
continuously
there's no they remember you know
I hate to make light of this but you
know there is
and I don't want to joke about it
because you know with covid-19 jokes if
I told one 99.9 of the people wouldn't
get it right
that was a joke you do want to though
yeah oh my God that was terrible yeah
but but a real joke is the mice right so
that they got this neural link
equivalent that we were able to read the
minds of these these mice and what they
were talking about so they got this
conversation going then one of my stuck
in the other says Hey listen you're
going to get this covid-19 vaccine
and you know what the other mic said he
said hell no they're still testing it in
humans
[Laughter]
uh wow I haven't heard it any covid-19
jokes
because it's just so
crazy you know what they're doing you
got your left is going to get you
through it so
but it brings to an emphasizes a central
point which is why I've mentioned it is
because there's no safety testing on
this done they've done these adequate
tests I mean these tests that are very
superficial very short term no animal
studies it normally takes 10 to 15 years
to get the back normal vaccine approved
uh there were previous coronavirus
vaccines that were not messenger RNA
they did them in ferrets and they uh
gave the ferris the vaccine and it
worked great all the ferrets got
immunity to the coronavirus right almost
100 percent High antibody levels and
everything and then you know what they
did they exposed the ferrets to the
coronavirus you know what happened to
the ferrets
they all died they all died they all
died
and and there was a mechanism for it uh
it's actually several names I like pie
which is paradoxical immune enhancement
but it's more typically called Ade
that's terrible everybody dependent
enhancement
um so yeah it's terrible right so this
is this is the the kicker because all
these people are getting immunized well
some of them will drop dead and usually
the acute reactions are autoimmune
reactions typically catalyzed by
exposure to one of the uh
materials they need to create the
liposome which is Peg or polyethylene
glycol and they have a acute reaction to
it and die that's just like a lot of tag
I thought Peg was supposed to be safe no
no just passed through you no no no no
it is not and especially when you inject
it no no way oh my God no way okay he's
not safe so anyway that but that that's
the phase one phase two is that gets an
injection they develop this antibody
dependent enhancement
or Pi paradoxical immune enhancement
paradoxical because the immune
enhancements is supposed to help help
you but in this case it kills you right
that's the Paradox
so who knows what's going to happen to
everyone who is immunized when they do
get exposed to either coronal flu virus
or the covet 19. who knows we don't know
it's never tested it's never been tested
this is one of the greatest the largest
experiments in human history Health
experiments
yeah and no one no one could deny it I
don't care who you have on to oppose
this views no one can deny the fact they
can't
next question this is this doesn't
really have this has something to do
with what we were talking about but how
do you feel about vaccine passports
oh my gosh that's a that's a whole road
that is one of the initial
strategies they're using to for the
wealth transfer they're going to
identify but it's in some ways it's
similar to what they did not to Germany
they're identifying these people you
know and you're going to be they're
going to say you know they're they're
going to get it where everyone wants it
and it's clamoring for it they're
creating this narrative in this
propaganda to convince people that this
is something they should they should
seek to have you know it's gonna because
it's going to ease the restrictions and
all the benefits for it when and when
actually it's going to be the one of the
worst things they can do that's what the
Nazis did with the Jews and
interestingly uh this is an interesting
aside that I there's a division of IBM
in World War II that worked with the
Nazi Germany to implement the
mechanization of this and facilitate
that from happening because there's no
way they could have done this they
needed a lot more sophisticated system
to do that and IBM helped them and guess
who's helping in the vaccine papers or
passports in the United States in the
21st century IBM
aren't they right now I don't know if I
saw it in Florida I think on somebody's
story that they were in a football
stadium and there was a section that
said vaccine P vaccinated people apply I
don't I don't know those and I don't I
don't recall seeing that specific story
I wouldn't be surprised to find that but
what their goal and anticipation is and
this is what we need to stop is they're
going to if they're going to segregate
the people who have been immunized and
who have not so even though these won't
be required mandatory vaccines literally
the it's going to be an effective
mandatory vaccine because you won't be
able to travel won't be going to flight
anywhere don't be able to go to a sports
event to a concert and eventually you
won't even be able to go into the
grocery store unless you got a vaccine
passport that's what they're doing
they're essentially making it virtually
impossible to live in a normal society
why would they want to do that to
everybody
like it
it was
somebody's master plan wouldn't they
didn't they have chosen certain people
or have they chosen just very few
certain people for for whatever reason
I'm still perplexed they have not
allowed me to sit in under meetings
so I don't know I just don't know but
it's not a good strategy I mean you can
the evidence is clear historically when
these types of interventions have been
have been implemented it's just not a
good outcome so we do not want this type
of identification system it's
unnecessary and it's all done on the
supposition that this vaccine works and
it's effective and it prevents the
disease and it doesn't it does not
prevent the disease all it was proven in
these fictitious studies where which do
prove don't prove safety at all is that
it lessens the symptoms and I want to
get back to these studies because you
you were concerned about infertility
do you know that in all these studies
how many pregnant women did they test
how many come on you can't test on women
right none yeah zero no pregnant women I
know and they're giving it to pregnant
women that's not cool like even if it
ends up being safe you should not
reprehensibly negligent malpractice yeah
I agree
that and they're giving it to kids and
it do you know the percentage of
children who die from covid
oh God I don't know
this way many who percentage who don't
it's like 99.99 it it's it's a very rare
occurrence for childhood diagrams
usually it's an immunocompromised child
or severely metabolically flexible
morbidly obese or some other
complication like
um may have had cystic fibrosis or
something but it's very very it almost
never happens and yet now they're
encouraging kids to get this vaccine I
mean if just take the pieces of the
puzzle the facts that we know are
indisputable non-controversial and think
put on the thinking cap that your God
gave you and think it through itself and
and stop listening to the propaganda you
cannot if you're rational you cannot
come to any other conclusion
you just can't
it's too obvious
okay next question
on a more positive note what should
people do what should people be doing uh
in regards to staying healthy against
covet love that I love to keep it
positive
is I alluded to this earlier you want to
be metabolically flexible and and so how
do you become metabolically flexible
there's a several powerful powerful
interventions that don't cost you
anything the most important one and the
topic of a book that I'm going to be
publishing next year is is essentially
to remove a very specific fat it's an
omega-6 fat it's called linoleic acid
have you ever heard of that before
I have are you happy to explain yeah but
I definitely will explain so no it's
normally considered to be what's called
an essential fat meaning your body needs
it because it can't make it but if you
eat food
if you eat food it's impossible to
become deficient in this fact because
it's almost in every food you know the
problem is we get too much of it and so
what's too much normally our ancient
ancestors got about to one to two
percent of the total calories of their
diet as linoleic acid now it's like 20
30 2
20 to 30 times more
it's crazy so what's the what's the big
deal well it's a high it's called a pufa
a polyunsaturated fat acid and it's
highly susceptible to oxidation
which is causes these damaging free
radicals which go on to damage your stem
cells cell membranes mitochondria uh and
as a result your energy is producing
structures become debilitated or just
destroyed and it becomes very difficult
to function and and it will radically
increase your risk of every single
chronic regenerative disease no demand
heart disease cancer dementia diabetes
obesity
everything arthritis so that is why
you've got to limit so how do you limit
linoleic acid you cannot have vegetable
oils you have to understand that if
vegetable oil is a metabolic poison the
most pernicious food toxin you can ever
hope to consume
or grains gluten looks like Health Food
compared to vegetable oil there's no
comparison now for some people it's
going to be a little bit worse
especially having really severe gluten
intolerance I don't recommend gluten but
I just want to give people a perspective
because they don't understand yet
virtually no Natural Health Care
clinicians get this
they will agree I mean really really
sharp people and I didn't understand
until about a year ago so I'm late to
the to the table too or to the party but
um it's it's so crucial to get this
because vegetable oil is the thing that
you've got to eliminate so that means
eliminate all processed foods and I will
I will debate anyone on this anyone at
any time because the evidence is
indisputable
and it just
makes me livid that this is not well
known and I'm hoping to populate this
concept because that will radically
improve the health of the country so
you've got to limit you've got to
eliminate every vegetable oil you can
have you can none of them are good none
of them there is no excuse to have a
vegetable oil so that means that you
have to look at processed foods that
means eliminating most of your
restaurant visits because there's almost
no restaurant that doesn't use vegetable
oils
they used to like I I read that I think
it was McDonald's used to use I don't
know if it was lard it was some sort of
yeah they did they use beef Tallow
typically they used Tallow that's crazy
no that is correct no and that is one of
the healthiest fats you can cook with is
beef towel especially from uh
organic grass-fed beef beef but even
regular kfo beef jelly was still a lot
better
so and there is an organization that is
probably on level of evil is evil as
Monsanto or Bill Gates
um it's called cspi which is an acronym
for Center for Science in the public
interest and they took out ads in the
late 80s and actually full page adjun
like USA Today and you know targeted
McDonald's and other fast food
restaurants about using beef Jello
because they they said you're killing
people and they convinced them to switch
over to this vegetable oil
they are responsible directly
responsible for killing tens prematurely
killing tens of millions of people tens
of millions of people
they're also responsible for leveling
criticism of me for bringing up the
things that I'm talking about and and
because of their encouragement and then
it did nothing happen in Trump
administration because they wrote an
article that got us on the front page of
New York Times in the Washington Post
and they were criticizing us for for
what we're saying and then they
encourage the FDA to write this letter
but they never did but since the moment
literally a week after Biden was
inaugurated then the FDA wrote us
awarding letter which had was 100
mirrorless stands there's no way that it
has any Merit at all it will be if it
ever goes accordingly similarly
dismissed without I mean that's it boom
there's no trial because there's no
merit for it but nevertheless they were
able to do that and you know they're
ever it's this whole collusion between
this corporate these multinational
corporations and the government it
really is a fascist it fascist fascism
in in in plain sight you know these
corporations are acting with the
government to deploy their their needs
so so it's happening but anyway cspi was
responsible for that transition
wow yeah you did did you know that
no I don't delve like I try and in order
to well you have done plenty good like a
great job with communicating with the
masses but in order to communicate in
the masses with masses I'm trying to
stay like
middle zone no some people who make it
hard I'm just like oh that sounds like
it could be true but like
not yet no I won't delve into it yet
um I'm trying to grow first yeah and go
off saying yeah yeah good point is I'll
get kicked off of YouTube no I know you
know we already grew we were the biggest
out there we're number one
um so we've you know we've and people
know knew about us one of this tragic
tragic outcomes or results of this
implementation is that people who know
us it's not an issue they can find us
they can subscribe to our daily
newsletter for free and and they'll have
the information so we're not taking off
the internet but we're essentially
for anyone new they'll never find us
because we're removed from the search
engine two years ago you would never
find US unless you knew someone that we
were a resource that was it
which is fine I mean we I mean we I've
I've helped hundreds of millions of
people fine we're a wolf I heard even
his website um oh yeah there's there's
dozens if not hundreds of us have been
taken off so anyone who's telling the
truth about this that understands the
reality of that your immune system that
works on this and it's not this magic
vaccine uh they're going to be taken off
there's no question so it's important to
know I mean if you're not involved in
this and you might be already know who
these resources are if you're watching
Michaela's Channel but if you aren't
that there's a lot of people out here
know what they're doing they're you're
just not going to easily find them but
as soon as you find a few the the you
know the breadcrumbs are out of to
everyone else and you'll eventually find
the rest of the rest of us
when Texas and Florida they've been open
did their hospitals ever overflow
it's the best of my knowledge I did not
I mean that was a justification for
implementing these shutdowns and the
lockdowns
is that
we
um what was the term they used uh
flatten the curve was it was the
collapse yeah yeah but that as soon as
they were able to implement the
lockdowns under the justification of
emergency measures that term disappeared
that term disappeared and even using the
justification of the term that
acknowledged that they would never
prevent the infections they would just
delay them so that they uh resources
would be available to to address the
sick people so that they wouldn't all
come in at the same time essentially
but they abandoned that now anyway no
one can get the disease if you got the
disease as one too many
you know so they've misclassified people
and it's just it it's it's just
absolutely surreal it's like we're
living in a dystopian or uh George
Orwell movie you know
um yeah it does feel like that do you
know any of the statistics behind some
of the side effects of lockdowns like
increasingly well they're suicide goes
yet but I'm pretty confident that the
the consequences of the the lockdown are
going to
exceed I mean even just the depression
the anxiety the suicides that it results
from this let alone the long-term
complications of of stopping children
from going to school and having social
interactions
it's just so beyond crazy so I think
it's it's significant I just don't
recall the numbers and there's just so
much of information it's just hard to
keep track of all the details this is
one I don't oh yeah well for sure I can
just ask you to bring up random
statistics but um I don't think some of
the statistics have been released like
because it's so early in the year I
think it takes a while for some things
to be released one of my main concerns
was
other than the increase in mental health
because I've suffered from mental health
issues but is delayed surgeries because
in Canada we already have a long waiting
list and there are like people who
really need help and their the hospital
section is closed down
and Slack
it boggles my mind yeah you're already
compromised because the Socialist
approach which and you can make I'm not
arguing for against it but you know
there are some downsides to it and then
you complicate it further with the other
restrictions and it just becomes
unbearable and people will die as a
result of that there's no question that
caused deaths it definitely caused
deaths
I mean just even the normal social
system might be not able to get a CAT
scan or MRI scan for months you know and
that is consequences
yeah okay
um what would
say this it's what would a reasonable
response to this virus have been like
what should the government have done oh
that is so easy to answer that is so
easy it's exactly what we talked about
what can people do to protect themselves
and I didn't really finish answering the
question because it's so easy for me to
go into tangents on this so you have to
build up your I talked about vegetables
and then we would that we just tangered
in from there so you got one you want to
build up your they should have
encouraged strategies to improve the
person's immune system what are those
strategies improve your metabolic
flexibility eliminate all vegetables all
processed foods mock optimize your
vitamin D levels and we had specific
discussions on this because that's a
huge issue for your autoimmune disease
so you have to have a healthy vitamin D
level if you live in Canada there's
almost no one it's impossible to have a
healthy vitamin D level in Canada unless
you're supplemented Because You're Just
Too Far North with home mandates stay at
home oh yeah yeah it's just not going to
have it so you have to take a supplement
and you have to measure your blood so
what is the number the number that
you're looking for if this is your U.S
audience then it's 60 to 80 nanograms
per ml that's the end exit their unit
that they're using in Canada or in
Europe these are different unit there's
nanomoles per liter and that's 100 to
150 nanomoles per liter just completely
cross out the normal reference range
because it's absolutely irrelevant they
don't know what the heck they're talking
about they're using ancient studies that
don't meet diddly squat if you want to
optimize your immune fix function is 60
to 80 nanograms per ml or 100 to 150
nanometers per liter that's what you
shoot for that's what you got to get
typically the average adult takes about
8 000 units a day to get to that level
assuming you have no exposures to
Sunshine now you don't have to take
vitamin D I haven't taken vitamin D in
12 years my level is 60 to 70 nanograms
so but you can get confused because you
were you were telling me your level was
55 and then I said you know you live in
Canada so they're using animals and
that's like less than 20 which is like
over close to 20. it was like Siri you
were seriously deficient in vitamin D so
and yours hopefully I'm less deficient
now yeah yeah yeah well you're but
you're heading there that's for you it's
I mean for all of us it's so important
but but with anyone with no autoimmune
disease it's it's just one of the most
important uh therapeutic interventions
you can have and it's like almost free
it's free for me I've been taking it for
10 years I just get it from the regular
Sun that's it
so as we're designed to get it not
everyone can do that as I understand
that most of us don't live in the
subtropics and have the freedom to go
out into the sunshine every day with not
much clothes on so although if you don't
do that you're not going to get it from
the zone
so the other thing so you really have to
go outside in a bathing suit to get it
from the Sun properties yeah that would
be a I like that description I never
said that I usually use longer more
complex terminology I but I like it
because essentially that's what I do we
recommend people do like in a woman is a
you know a sports bra or a bathing suit
that's the way that's exactly what you
need and it's got to be during solar
noon like in daylight savings times that
would be one o'clock and non-door
daylight savings it's 12 o'clock
so um
um so doing that
and then if you do get infected what the
most important strategy I would go to my
site and mercola.com merconlady.com and
type in uh nebulized hydrogen peroxide
I've done the many interviews on it and
and created a specific interview that
gives you detailed instructions on how
to implement this because it uses a
nebulizer you have to Devil's in the
details you have to get a good nebulizer
because most of them are bad they're
inexpensive and they don't work you get
like so it's only six or eighty dollars
it's probably the best hundred dollar
investment you can make because it will
last for years and at the moment you get
sick you just use a very small
concentration because normally the
peroxide in your drugstore is like three
percent these this you would use a 0.1
percent so it's like 30 times diluted
and you dilute it with normal saline
which is a saltwater solution and all
the instructions on how to do it are in
there and if you do that you do like
every hour where you're sick
it's like incredibly effective it's like
well over 90 maybe Beyond 95 effective I
mean it's the craziest strategy and it's
and after you've made the investment for
the nebulizer the peroxide is free I
mean the dose that you're going to use
is less than a penny it's like less than
a tenth of a penny that's how much
peroxide you're using so
it you know and anyone can use it and
you just inhale it and breathe it in for
a few minutes and and almost everyone
the cough disappears the fever gets
better the feeling that they're going to
die just is gone I mean what I've so
many of my the friends and relatives I
know to use this and it's exactly the
experience they get and David bronstein
oh yeah it's everyone should have this
there's probably a justification use at
least once or twice a week to improve
your microbiome independent of that so
yeah I I don't know if you if this is
going to be a video if you're going to
article that goes with it but you can
put the links to the to the video where
it's described that would help a lot of
people out and they can see yeah I can
do that because I I go through 15 or 20
minutes to explain the reason why
peroxide works and justification report
and more importantly walk you through
how to create the solution because you
got to have it in your home if you don't
if you don't have it in your home it's
not going to work but there's a benefit
to even doing it twice a week even if
you don't have covert or flu or anything
but boy if you've got a flu the moment
you have a sniffle or sneeze or a cough
boom you do this and literally once or
twice and it's gone it is gone it's
crazy and there's virtually no side
effects if you do it properly you know
very low concentration there's no side
effects it's almost it's almost free and
it works I mean what better what better
prescription because if if they had a
magic
uh
drug that you take this pill and you're
better well they'd have to make it and
you know almost every pharmaceutical has
side effects and there's a cost to it
they couldn't make it fast enough they'd
have to create hundreds of millions of
doses but that all you need is a
nebulizer all you need is nebular and
peroxide which is there's more than a
peroxide to treat the entire population
of the world
um so it's an effective intervention it
works so those are the strategies
because I'm all this is answering your
initial question which I thought was
brilliant was what can the average
person do what are what should the
government have done to do this is the
same thing the government should have
courage these structures and
interventions because that that would
have reduced the death rate from covid
um 50 is brain dead I mean it's probably
somewhere between 70 to 90 percent
70 90 yeah yeah
okay Dr Mercola I'm out of time okay is
it is there anything else you want to
add no get the book you get the book
yeah cover 19. I mean okay
yeah.com so you know you will not find
me in Google you won't find me on you
well I think we have a YouTube channel
but you know anything important we can't
put on there so
but uh yeah it's been great I just uh
cherish the time to with you and the
opportunity to help you with your own
issues because you know you're just I I
just love people like you who get it and
have the mental tenacity to go and
restriction yourself and take control of
your health because you can do it and
you're such an inspiration as everyone
out there so thanks for what you do
thank you very much
I appreciate it
[Music]
Dr Camille welcome to my podcast
nice to be here thanks for having me on
this is going to be a big episode we're
discussing all things covid and we have
two points of view here so
here we go
question number one
is covet a flu
um is a dog a bird
no it's a totally different viruses
okay here's a question then how how why
are there no flu cases anymore that's a
that's because masks are really
effective at suppressing vile
transmission and the social distancing
that was enforced I mean Australia we
knew this was going to be a mild full
year for us when we saw Australia
because they get the flu six months
before we do their winter is upside down
relative to ours that's why you can like
ski in the southern hemisphere during uh
some with Summer here
um so when you wear masks and people
don't gather indoors flu doesn't spread
well either so it's historically low
it's pretty amazing it shows you that
these days what they're called
non-pharmaceutical interventions they
really work
to me who knows really nothing about
this it looks like flu flu cases could
have been miscategorized as covid cases
like Canada I think had zero cases it
seems unbelievable zero case there's no
way that that's possible yeah yeah I
think there's probably cases I mean
every time the government counts
something it's always under counting it
almost almost always because people
don't go to like hospitalizations yeah I
mean you have to have like some big
Corporation do a swab and register a
test with the government bureaucracy for
it to exist in a case number A lot of
times you get a fever and if you just
feel better taking some Motrin or
hanging out at home resting you don't
necessarily get a test there's no
official result of your flu case there's
definitely flu cases but they're they're
down like I think like well over tenfold
perhaps even more than that this year
it's it's a tiny amount of cases
okay before we get into it can you give
a brief background about who you are and
what it is you do yeah so I'm first of
all uh my name is Jeremy Camille I have
studied uh what herpes viruses really
for the last 20 years I'm not a
coronavirologist I'm not a medical
doctor I don't prescribe drugs I don't
treat disease don't take anything I say
as medical advice but I do know a lot
about viruses and how they enter cells
because I've studied that you know it's
one of my passions is studying how
viruses work we rip out a gene and put
like a green Gene from a jellyfish in it
to see like make the cells glow and
understand where a viral protein does
how it escapes from the immune system
that kind of super nerd stuff that most
of the time people don't pay attention
to but then all of a sudden the pandemic
they're like oh your job's useful again
go help us
um so they shut down our campus and told
us we couldn't work on any of the
viruses that we were funded by the NIH
or the you know the government to work
on for our research we compete for
Grants and they said the only thing
you're allowed to do on campus right now
is help set up a covid-19 testing
facility and so that's how I started
working on covid-19 because it's not
research it's like trying to respond to
a public health emergency
wow so they turn to everybody's research
towards the pandemic at least for a few
months the first like during the
shutdown it was you stay home or and if
you're coming to campus if we if you're
caught just for liability issues like
because everything was closed if you
weren't like treating patients or
involved in like ramping up testing
because you realize the government
totally failed us on testing they didn't
have any tests ready and the tests they
tried to roll it didn't work so we were
asked by the governor of Louisiana and
state senator Bill Cassidy and our an
intern our Chancellor hey can you help
out can you guys set up a test and we're
like yeah I mean the technology to do
this PCR test is something that you know
if you have even a high school
level understanding of biology it's not
that complicated and I'm a big believer
for actually personally in that the
average person in the public should be
fully in charge of their health and
power to understand how things in
medicine work
um and so you know just that's my belief
for everyone you treat everyone like an
intellectual equal no matter where their
background is and um so I thought well
of course we can do this this isn't like
that magical but it does have to be
emergency authorized by the FDA and as a
scientist you want to look at what's
worked for other scientists and
scientists tend to be very transparent
about their methods you have to publish
what primers you used and how you did
the assay and so we you know developed
an assay that was you know we didn't
invent new primers we tested the ones
that other people were using and started
a test and then then from that it
evolved to well it'd be nice to sequence
the whole genome because you can now do
really amazing things to trace how the
virus is moving almost like a CSI crime
set you know like if there's like if the
murder at least blood of the crime scene
you can figure out who his grandma was
because based on the the DNA sequence
and so we're using those things to trace
the pandemic and watch how it evolves
and then
um we developed and we implemented an
antibody test invented by a group at
Mount Sinai uh New York and New York
City
um a guy named Florian Cromer so we
could test people's blood to see who had
been infected yet because a lot of
people get infected and have very mild
symptoms if any and so you need to know
who's immune and who's not just to
understand basic things and then we
built a new assay uh together mostly
invented by a guy named Ben Hurley at
Icon not Sinai
slow Madison New York again a close
collaborator of mine it's like a green
virus it has a spike on it but it's like
a safer virus we just basically took the
spike protein Gene out of the
coronavirus and he put it in a
relatively harmless virus that glows
green and so now we can test people's
blood for whether their antibodies
neutralize infection and we recently got
trolled by the Sputnik five the Russian
vaccine uh company on Twitter because we
published some serum from collaborator
in Argentina who put people who had been
fully immunized against Sputnik
um to No Surprise those that
immunization was not that effective
against the b1351 variant that emerged
in South Africa
um and so they weren't happy that we
shared that information even though it
wasn't really a surprise a lot of the
major vaccines are to a large degree
escaped by the mutations on the spike so
it's evolved from like testing for
Coronavirus to limit cases in nursing
homes because in those places like one
out of eight people were dying or more
and so I mean those are all people some
people say oh well they're forgotten
they're too old they need to die anyway
I think that's what's what's the usual
what's the usual uh death rate for flus
in nursing homes I think it depends from
year to year what the flu is but those
are more vulnerable people for sure if
you're in your 80s and you get a flu
infection depending on the year there
can be mild ones and more nasty ones um
you're more vulnerable but I don't want
to make people think that these viruses
are only dangerous to elderly people
um being healthy jogging having a great
diet is not an insurance policy have
been something like Ebola loss of fever
virus or even a flu like the 1918 uh
1919 flu that flu killed people in their
20s what about what about covet though
covid um is definitely more dangerous
for you as you get above 40. especially
if you're overweight or have high blood
pressure or pre-existing condition but
there's also College athletes who got
what they thought was a mild case of
covid and then six months later they're
still suffering random like headaches uh
even psychiatric disturbances this is a
weird virus it does weird things that
are unpredictable some kids very young
kids most kids are it's like one in ten
thousand as a child if you're exposed to
the virus that you would die from it but
a reasonable if you're the mother of a
child who ends up with multi-system
inflammatory disease from covid you're
not too stoked to hear you know these
people telling you about how it's
harmless to kids
this virus killed a a guy who was not
overweight it was a newly elected State
uh sorry a congressman to the to the U.S
federal Congress he was about to be
inaugurated I think on January 3rd or
something of this year and on December
29th he died in our hospital just like
you know several hundred yards to the
left of me uh he was not he was
medevaced in from Monroe Louisiana his
name is Luke letlow he left he left
behind two young children and a wife
who's now uh was elected to his seat in
Congress but he was in his early he was
41 years old and he died from covid-19
on December 29th right here so it's it's
very we don't we scientists do not
completely understand why certain people
get fatally ill and others don't but
you're talking about a virus that if you
let it go unrip if you let it rip and
have people at bars and karaoke it's not
just your infection risk if you get a
whopping dose like if someone breathes a
ton of it on you and you aren't worried
at all you're not masking and you're not
defending yourself I mean you're giving
the virus like a four-lane super highway
to zoom right to your deep in your lungs
and cause a lot of problems and so it's
definitely a serious risk for people um
even my age you know and like it's just
funny hearing some of the discussion on
Twitter social media people like
pretending the virus doesn't exist or
it's not a threat at all like you see a
lot of people change their mind or you
see a post about someone who thought
that way and then they die and you know
that's no one deserves that even if
you're you don't deserve to die just
because you're wrong this is one of
those situations where it shouldn't be a
political thing at all we should all be
basically getting the real facts in our
communities not just from like Tony
fauci or some federal Authority we
should be talking to the people who
treat cases in our communities who we
actually trust and who have you know who
aren't don't have an agenda like the
only agenda should be truth like
transparency and Truth
I completely agree okay I'm gonna run
through some questions sure where I'm
from uh in Ontario
it's completely under lockdown and they
close down schools and there's a
stay-at-home mandate right now it's one
of the strictest lockdowns in North
America uh And Then There Are Places
like Texas that are open so uh in your
opinion what kind of response is the
proper response to this kind of pandemic
well I think it has to be driven by case
numbers and by what's safe and what's
not safe in the beginning of the
pandemic we didn't really understand
enough about how it spread so the
guidance was like you if you remember
like wash your hands it's so important
and like the playgrounds were like taped
off like they were crime scenes turns
out the virus does not spread
efficiently outside at all
um it can happen if you're like up close
to close to someone or if you're in like
a dense like if you're like a stadium
sporting events and everyone's screaming
and howling this this stuff spreads by
droplets and where people are crowded
with poor ventilation so I think bets
are off about like knowing the indoor
outdoor transmission risk is very very
low I'm not going to say it's zero but
relatively speaking if you're like if
you're going to spend your effort wisely
like we're like it's a hassle to wear a
mask collar game some people get used to
it and I have friends and colleagues who
like wear it all day because they work
at like Harvard Medical School and the
policies are so strict there that
they're just like used to wearing a mask
and 95 all day
um myself I like to take it off when I'm
walking outside so what's a what's a
reasonable
um what's a reasonable response should
be driven by the case number in your
area the case number in your area is is
reasonably low and the public health
messaging is accurate and people are
doing the right things like they aren't
ignoring the guidance then the case
numbers will stay low enough and we can
keep businesses open and do stuff
responsibly but when when there's a new
virus out there like b117 this variant
that is about 50 more deadly and about
60 percent more transmissible like
relatively
um that virus spreads a lot better and
it's actually spreading better in
children than the prep than the original
virus so the virus is evolving as it
infects us and the reason it's evolving
is because the pandemic's not under
control so it's all these ironic things
like a rich person can afford to spend
more but if you spend all your money all
of a sudden you don't have any money to
spend so if you're too careful with a
public health response then you know
you're going to control the cases and
that's a good thing
um but you're gonna like lose public
support but Vice Versa if you leave if a
leader is like oh I don't care at all or
just every business should be open
because it's too much risk for the
economy and case numbers explode and
hospitals are really crowded and
overflowing which is which happened in
Texas this summer I mean we stayed at a
motel on the way to Colorado to visit my
uh to visit my to get together with my
family member we all got tests my
parents like five young kids and fish
are their grandparents so we all got
tested and we we joined together and got
you know in Colorado but on the way
there you know some some of the motels
were all booked with ER nurses like
they're they were like traveling nurses
who who like there were so many of them
there treating covet patients that there
weren't even
were the hospitals in Texas ever
overflowing like did they ever turn away
patients this absolutely happened in
certain parts of southern Texas and and
I'm guessing Amarillo as well
um it's well documented they were they
were overflowing patients to a pediatric
hospital adult patients were going to a
children's hospital because there
weren't beds left in in the Houston area
I think that that got bad around this
this winter was the worst like January
was really the peak of where Hospital
Systems you saw them getting strained
did that happen in Florida too
I don't you know I don't keep track of
all all the stuff like I'm not the
world's encyclopedia on on all the
things that happened I would love to
have that data for you I do think there
was strain on the hospital systems from
what I understand I don't know if
Florida specifically overflowed
it's funny because Ontario so as a kid I
was really sick and I was in emergency
like literally every four months and we
I was always treated in the hall because
it was always completely full and in
last last January Ontario came out with
this or Toronto came out with this um
article and it was like hospitals are at
hospital ERS are at 86 capacity right
and this was in January and then in
March April May and then in December
something came out and it was like 87
hospitals are overflowing and it had
changed by three percent but the public
health officials had switched it into
you know now it's a problem even though
it had been a problem before so it's
hard for me to
especially in Ontario it's hard for me
to understand why you would close things
down because of the okay okay anyway no
you're right let's skip
I mean the one thing I would say though
is talk to the people working in the
hospitals like the Infectious the
respiratory therapists the nurses who
take care of sick people because it's
not all about beds it's like how tired
is the person taking care of the patient
if they're working like 16 extra shifts
and not getting any sleep because
there's so many patients it doesn't
matter how many ventilators there are if
you don't have people to run them like
so I would just like reach out to your
Canadian Public Health Community and be
like hey what's the scuttlebutt like
what's really like you know because
those people I find are really honest
like they're brutally honest when they
disagree with like a math mandate
they'll tell you they'll be like oh this
is kind of this is silly the cases
aren't that bad or they'll be like oh my
gosh this is really terrible I wish more
people wore their mask like because
they're the ones taking care of sick
people that I think you can trust them
yeah that's fair it's fair uh okay okay
next question this is a good one so the
more right-wing View at the moment uh
for whatever reason is that the dangers
of lockdowns uh vastly outweigh the
dangers of covid that's why places like
Texas are open and Florida's open and
you know New York's shut down so their
view is you know increase in suicide
delayed surgeries vastly I would say
outweighs the dangers of covid
it's funny because in your opinion well
all I know is there's a really cool
article that just came out in one of the
Lancet journals um and it was based on
data in Massachusetts I used to live in
Massachusetts there's a lot of depressed
people there trust me it's like high
stress especially in Boston suicide
rates were lower this year this like
during the pandemic than they were the
year before by a little bit really yeah
I mean I wouldn't say it's like
statistically significant because you
have to like you know but it's not
higher no not at all it's lower so and
they have like they're charting it over
over many years I even have like the
graph somewhere I printed it out because
I've got a kick out of that I came
across my screen on uh on Twitter I was
like well that's funny because I've
heard that argument a lot of times too
yeah
below I mean I think it is a bummer to
have a lockdown but again it's one of
those things that if we did a better job
controlling the pandemic and all
agreeing on what the threat is instead
of dividing against ourselves
politically and deciding that oh the
virus is a myth or it's too small and it
can get through a mask and like not even
a green about basic things because we're
getting divided and conquered by people
who want to divide and conquer us and we
aren't like focused on the truth and
getting along as like a community and
when people can't agree and you have
like a zombie you know biting people
like if we were like in a zombie movie
you didn't believe in zombies like you
know it's not such a surprise that the
zombie apocalypse gets gets out of
control this is an invisible enemy it's
a virus and we can't even agree about
germ Theory I mean this is like
scientifically settled stuff from like
you know hundreds of years now but you
have people effectively you know scaring
each other or Hawking like homeopathic
cures they absolutely don't work and
there's no basis for them but they want
to sell you products and they want to
like you know and then you have the
government on the other side wanting to
strip mine the genetic data of the
coronavirus and dump it into like
databases and like not Empower your
community so scientists like don't all
agree with each other we disagree with
each other all the time it's not like
science versus non-science it's just
like what's the truth what's really
happening and who can you trust
yes definitely I think the reason a
zombie apocalypse would get out of
control though is because one bite just
kills you that's true that's probably a
good point or you'll turn you into this
okay
turns you into a zombie that's true
kills you and then turns don't you die
before you're a zombie you're the undead
technically like a vampire that's my
like secret research project you're not
gonna talk about it right now
okay
okay uh okay do you know anything about
this the great reset
I I looked it up because you you said
something about it it's like something
from the global economic Forum or
something like that am I right or the
world economic Forum I'd never heard of
it until you you want to tell me about
it so you can educate me
no that's okay we'll skip that question
okay okay what about this question
um so another view that's out there is a
that this is a plan for the elite to
take over given how hard this has been
on poor people and jobs that we're
getting forced into vaccinations it's
being run by the government the
pharmaceutical and the elite it's making
the rich richer
it's taking aware of freedoms if we
don't get the vaccine how do you feel
about that theory well I think that's a
pretty bad Theory because the poor are
suffering the most from the virus if you
are a a person who lives in a crowded
house who cannot socially distance I
mean the people are getting crushed by
this are prisoners who don't have access
to vaccines
um people who have to show up at their
job as a bus driver regardless I mean
those people want the vaccine as as much
or more than the rich but you see the
rich kind of cutting in line trying to
get it faster because no one wants to
get sick I mean even Trump apparently
got the vaccine on the DL like he didn't
announce it he went and got like
inoculated you know it's like you want
to be protected I mean remember the
thing about vaccines is that they allow
you like you you can teach a man to fish
but you know if if or you can give him
fish if if you can fish for yourself
you're going to be able to eat many
meals and I don't have to like catch
your fish for you your immune system is
a great a great uh amazing uh complex
beautiful like Symphony Orchestra of
evolution that defends your body against
all kinds of things like it's like got a
CIA and FBI beat cops it's got a whole
bunch of different cells that do
different jobs and a vaccine just gives
it a mug shot of hey here's the bad guy
look out for this dude and so it can
make its own cells to fight it so you
don't need a pharmaceutical company
giving you recombinant antibodies in a
hospital bed and building you you know
thousands and thousands of dollars like
a vaccine enables your body's own native
intelligence to fight diseases the same
way you would fight the disease if you
were naturally infected and came up with
the best immune response because immune
responses are very different from person
to person but a vaccine a good one gets
the most effective vaccine response from
the most people it mimics what you would
the protection you get from Catching
like natural measles and getting better
from it without risking like one in a
thousand rate of fatal pneumonia from
measles which happens or or women will
lose their baby prematurely if they
happen to catch measles while they're
pregnant so those are terrible outcomes
and if you're talking to four or five
friends it doesn't seem like a risk that
any of you are going to die from that
because one at a thousand that's nothing
but if you like if you live in a city of
millions you start to know people who
died like and and if it's a preventable
death it's kind of a sad thing like why
would you not want to protect yourself
like it's just yeah yeah
I I I get that people are concerned
right now that this mRNA vaccine is new
that it wasn't tested for very long
um and that there might be side effects
we don't know of because the testing
phase wasn't very long and that if
you're young and healthy and your
chances of getting bad coveted or
statistically aren't bad then why should
they get the vaccine
um have there been other
mRNA vaccines that
are common or that we've used to see
what the long-term effects are as far as
I know this is the very first mRNA
vaccine in people but let me demystify
why mRNA vaccines are so um from a
regulatory standpoint which means and
the reason those regulations like the
FDA is one of the best organizations
like as far as protecting your health
and watching out for like Americans like
they are very very conservative about
what they will approve for use in humans
um so much so that the big Pharma
companies aren't universally happy about
it you know but they they do have to
play by the rules to get their vaccines
and their diagnostic tests and any
therapy approved so these this vaccine
is emergency youth authorized it's not a
formally approved therapy or a vac it's
not really a therapy it's a vaccine okay
um
the thing to know is that mRNA is um
something that our cells make all the
time to it's like it's your RAM if
you're a compute if you're new if your
DNA code or your genetic code is your uh
hard drive the the RNA that's translated
is like the temporary message and so RNA
always breaks down it's not there
forever but it can tell your little you
have little machines in your cells every
single one of your living cells has
little machines in it called ribosomes
that translate the genetic code and what
viruses do is hijack them they take over
the cell and they turn it into a virus
Factory this this RNA is basically looks
a lot like the RNA our own cells make
and what's exciting about it is it
doesn't have much else in it so there's
just the way to get it across the cell
membrane it's called a lipid
nanoparticle it's basically the thing
that's stuff that looks like stuff that
already is around our cells and bodies
but it gets the message across the
membrane and makes just one viral
protein so it's so simple from a
regulatory standpoint they do have to to
test it and make sure it's safe but when
you take a lot of other vaccines they're
much more complicated they have like a
replicating virus in them that's
weakened and passage in cell culture it
has a whole bunch of viral Protein
that's making and it was like grown in
cells which you know maybe were made
like people object to some of these
cells because they were made in the
1970s from like an aborted uh fetus or
something uh or a cancer cell line or
something that or a chicken embryo and
people are kind of freaked out by that
this mRNA is just purely made from the
same biochemicals that make up our
bodies like it's it's our own genetic
code just like the virus does use our
genetic code against us the the MRNA
flips on the virus and and says okay
cool we're just going to take out the
one thing that we need to defend our to
know about to defend our bodies from
covid-19 and we're going to give you the
secret message of what you need to know
here's the mug shot of the bad guy in
mRNA form it's going to self-destruct
after it makes like a few copies of this
protein and then your little like your
immune cells are like dude this guy
looks weird and there and they're going
to grab the the cell that is expressing
the weird Protein that's from this virus
that came from the MRNA and they're
going to take a little fragments of that
you know dying little cell in your arm
and bring it to a lymph node which is
basically like the CIA station of your
immune system and they're going to
compare notes and look at it and then
they'll make a whole bunch of custom
cells so instead of being like regeneron
to sell you a multi-thousand dollar
antibody infusion you'll know how to
make your own and you'll make these
amazing like antibody shields in your
mouth and your nose that that when the
virus like if someone breathes on you
and you get covered in your nose you
won't even know it because it's blocked
before it can even get into your cell
and that's an amazing thing so they had
already been working on mRNA vaccines
for a long time so they had a lot of
other ones in Trials so they already had
a pretty strong safety signature but
that's not enough for the FDA they
needed to see a lot of data from
patients so that so A number of
companies got bankrolled a lot by
taxpayers Pfizer went their own way and
bankrolled it themselves but they they
tested on like 30 000 people and they
had to shoot they had to record every
single adverse event if I got hit by a
car after getting the vaccine that's
still recorded as an adverse effect
adverse reaction and they have to vet
that hey did this car somehow hit them
because of the vaccine and if the
doctors have to go look at the facts and
be like no looks like you know A truck
hit the guy crossing the street had
nothing to do with the vaccine or the
person you know had a heart attack they
have to go look did the vaccine have
anything to do with that um yes or no
and they recorded every single thing
that happened to thousands of people and
they they determined that this vaccine
is extremely safe and and not only that
they were able to test that it's really
really effective ironically because the
pandemic was so poorly controlled
um they were able to find out it was
safe faster because so many of the
people who in the in the group that
didn't get the vaccine came down with
covid and at day 12 post post uh
inoculation of the first shot you saw
the curve separate like that and it was
just it's like it was it just crushed
the ability of this virus to make you
sick it and if you look in like South
Africa like there's a lot of like poor
people in Africa who don't have access
to the vaccine and even the healthcare
workers don't have access to it and you
saw that the few people who were in
these trials were really protected from
hospitalizations and deaths yet us rich
countries like Europe and the US are
hoarding the really good vaccines while
like people in lower and middle income
countries are having to wait or maybe
buy ones that are a little bit like not
as well proven as the the best ones we
have access to here in the US so I think
the Wrong conversation is like oh should
we trust the vaccine
um you should you should find data on
your own from reputable sources don't
like don't don't get data from someone
who's trying to sell you something if
someone's like selling a health
supplement online or has something
they're profiting from don't look to
them for information look to people who
aren't like making a buck off of it and
talk to medical professionals like talk
to the ones who actually study
infectious diseases don't talk to an eye
doctor to find out about a vaccine
against a respiratory virus that person
it's like it's like talking to someone
who fixes like uh TVs and asking them
like hey what's what's up with my car
why is it broken like that's the wrong
expertise
okay that was actually a really good
explanation of an mRNA vaccine so thank
you uh to play devil's advocate here
sure
aren't aren't the um aren't the
pharmaceutical companies making money
each time somebody's vaccinated
um yeah they have giant contracts but
like you know I hope you're making a
buck filming the show I mean we all
gotta feed our kids like if you want
someone to do something yeah I mean like
Taylor Swift probably doesn't show up on
stage and sing a song like completely
for free unless it's a charity gig the
people I know who made the vaccines like
I I'm I personally know uh one of the
people who invented the lock Spike
protein he's at University of Texas at
Austin his name is Jason McLellan and
it's really cool like he and another guy
named Barney Frank who's like all about
giving like young people
um especially from diverse backgrounds
like like leadership roles and science
like like empowering like young black
women to have just as important a job as
Tony fauci it's like one of the best
most generous like oriented to like
what's good for people and trying to
help them give people the truth and
figure out how to protect human health
they figure out how to lock the spike
protein in the configuration that it
needs to be in to do its job it's like a
spring-loaded thing that pulls the virus
into yourself a harpoon almost it like
fuses the viral membrane with your cell
membrane and then releases that Rogue
genetic code of the virus that turns
your cell into a virus Factory and you
don't want your cell to be a virus
Factory trust me
um so they lock the fusion protein and
the pre-fusion Comfort that's what it's
called and that's the one that you want
antibiotics against that works it's
almost like if you're trying to protect
a mouse from a mousetrap like a
mousetrap goes you know like that and if
you were to make antibodies to lock the
you know if if the if the mouse traps in
the closed position you can't save a
mouse by like targeting that uh version
of the of The Mousetrap It's Already
Done its job it's already killed the
mouse like so the fusion protein of a
lot of these viruses it's
thermodynamically it's holding a lot of
energy it does work and the um it likes
to end up in the post-fusion
confirmation like after it's done its
job and antibodies against that do
nothing for you they're useless they
bind to parts of the protein that aren't
even like relevant to protecting you
from infection so these guys geniusly
came up with a way to lock it into the
pre-fusion conformer which focuses your
immune system's attention on exactly the
thing that's going to block the the
Rogue virus from getting into your cell
and so I know these people they're good
people they're this guy invented a new
version of it that they're allowing
people to use in like Vietnam for like
almost no cost like these people and
moderna is not enforcing their pets
right now on their their mRNA vaccine
because they're not like they really I
mean we all are suffering our economies
are suffering because of the disease so
to just like be like oh well they're
making money so it must be a bad vaccine
or they're rushing it that's not true I
mean the FDA is not making a buck or a
profit approving things like
inappropriately and in fact there was a
lot of tension during the last
administration because the um the people
in power or in the federal government
we're trying to push the FDA to approve
things faster or like drugs like
hydroxychloroquine which absolutely
don't work like because they wanted to
score a political win and and health
should not be political it has to be
based in facts like you don't want to
like lie to people or help someone get
elected by saying oh we've got the Cure
you know like there's a guy Jared
bolsonaro in in Brazil they have the
worst out of control pandemic basically
in the world right now or one of them
um and some of the scariest variants are
emerging from this lack of control of
the virus because every time you let the
virus like infect a new person and make
them sick it's like it's like buying
someone a coin at a slot machine and
giving them a coin like every once in a
while like most of those like infections
aren't going to mutate into like a
scarier virus or one that escapes
antibodies or infects people better but
every once in a while it gets the three
cherries in the slot machine and the
virus comes up with new mutations that
make it a little better at infecting
children which we don't want and
spreading between people silently and
even in fact acting people who already
recovered from covet so all these issues
are linked vaccines like believing in
vaccines understanding how masks work
like controlling the pandemic being
honest with people like approving drugs
that actually work and vaccines that
actually work like anyway my message is
that the FDA doesn't make a dollar more
if by by uh approving a vaccine first
and they and that's a separation of
power and a good one I don't believe the
government does everything right I don't
believe the Gates Foundation does
everything right in fact I think they
they both do a lot of things wrong but
with this with this vaccines like this
set of vaccines against covid-19 the FDA
and the US government and these
pharmaceutical companies moderna bio
intact Pfizer and Johnson and Johnson
the three that are approved so far those
have all done amazing transparent work
to protect public health and we should
celebrate that I mean if you get one of
those vaccines you're almost 100 percent
uh impossible for you to die from covet
even if you caught b117 even if you
caught like the scariest experience we
know of you will not end up with
pneumonia in the hospital you might
still catch the virus a little bit and
you might spread it but and that's why
people of all ages even if you are
younger and like oh it's not going to
make me sick well do you want to be part
of a transmission chain that gets the
virus into a prison full of people who
aren't even there for like like some of
those people in there are innocent
probably they were like sent to prison
or they were they're on like a drug
charge or they're just poor and black
and didn't have a good lawyer and these
people don't have a choice to socially
distance and they're at the mercy of
whatever State Governor feels and some
people are like oh they're prisoners so
we should vaccinate them last which I
think is really inhumane it's like
that's like a that's like an evil
experiment like if you're if you're
locking people up like if you can't
vaccinate and release them like that's
just inhumane and so do you want to be
part of a transmission chain you go out
to a bar you're young you're fine I
don't need it and then you give to
someone else who gives it to someone
else who gives it to someone else and
then that person's girlfriend works at a
prison in an office and then she's
talking to someone who's award award and
he has it to a guard and then all of a
sudden 600 people in a prison have
coveted because they they don't get to
separate from the person who's their
soulmate they don't get to distance when
they're at the cafeteria and old folks
home like do you want to be part of a
transmission chain that kills someone's
girlfriend or mother or gets like one of
those rare instances when a kid gets
like multi-system inflammatory disease
or long covet like we have 25 year old
professional football player athletes or
college athletes who are like done with
their their football career because
they're one of the rare examples of like
you know one in a thousand people in
their 20s who is really really gets ill
from it or doesn't think they got that
ill but then all of a sudden like they
can't breathe that well for months and
they can't like run like they used to
and that's messed up I mean why would
you want that is part of that
yeah yeah okay okay one oh
that was very interesting
um
that was very hold on let me look at my
list of questions
my concern with um how covet has been
treated
is the lack of Statistics behind what
happens when you lock down people
and what the what the side effects are
like I know people who've had serious
surgeries moved and in Toronto because
they closed down sections of the
hospital they had like cancer patients
waiting for cancer and because we have a
free health care System you can't really
pay ahead you have like deadly Cancers
and their surgeries are being delayed so
my concern is you know when you shut
down Society or slow down Society to
focus on one aspect that is potentially
dangerous you ignore all the other
aspects that are potentially dangerous
that might add up to more dangers that's
my concern totally agree with you I mean
I think there's no one who's Pro
lockdown no one likes no one likes a
lockdown Physicians don't like it
Ontario likes likes a lot the leadership
sees it as necessary and and if people
like I I don't know enough about
specifics on the ground about but I
doubt like anyone's getting rich locking
down I mean all the businesses don't
want to lock down the government makes
less tax the new when they're locked
down but they don't they're they're
probably being very very careful because
maybe they're freaked out about this
grant called b117 which is freaking a
lot of people out because it's so fast
at spreading
um and so if people get the vaccine and
if people wear masks and and and like
agree about like hey let's not crowd
indoors then I think the lockdowns
become less necessary I don't I don't
wouldn't want to be a governor
announcing a lockdown I think everyone
can agree lockdowns suck no no one likes
lockdowns I don't think any of the
health leaders like lockdowns I would
just make the argument that the
beginning of the pandemic and when
something feels out of control they tend
to they tend to react in a they try to
react in a way that's going to bring the
case numbers down because that that
draws down transmission and as soon as
you get the case numbers low enough we
can start to be indoors eating without a
mask on or doing a lot of things that we
used to do before but you know it's like
it's just funny I mean I don't want to
get into politics and lockdowns because
that's that's hairball like and I think
some states need United States have been
a little bit overzealous about like
mathematics like why should you have to
wear a mask if you're like alone on a
beach like you know without 100 people
around you for hundreds of like hundreds
and hundreds of feet and a high Breeze
like there's not like you're not going
to be spreading covet we know that like
scientists know that but that's the law
sometimes in certain places and like you
know I don't like you know I like to I
like to follow laws that I agree with
that make sense to me so I think the
challenges on those leaders to explain
why the lockdown is important and and
what the benefit is to you of like you
know you're a citizen you're affected by
this lockdown you know this is this is
why we're doing it but I'm not going to
try to pitch your lockdown to you I mean
it obviously sucks to walk down
obviously I I think I think part of the
reason there's so much insecurity around
the vaccine is because there are these
mandates where it's like wear a mask on
the beach uh and people are like well
that doesn't make sense why why should
we trust anything else you say it's just
backfiring terribly like I I know in
some countries they were they did a very
strict lockdown maybe for three months
where it was like you're stuck inside
your house in some countries then they
slowly opened up they had a rise in
cases managed to get vaccines and they
and then they opened up it was this huge
Spike and then it was just like you know
masks some of them are masks outside
still but they opened up and with Canada
and areas of the U.S it's just gone like
this and people are so freaked out
they're like I don't trust anything
you're putting out there yeah well it's
not a poor problem well they start to
trust it again when their friends get
sick I mean like I live in Louisiana
there's a pretty conservative state so a
lot of people are skeptical of the
mandates but a lot of my conservative
friends came down with covet and their
attitudes changed about it after they
were kind of freaked out like or they
kind of joke about it after but they
were like wow you know I was like I was
watching my blood oxygen go down I was
not freaked out like and these are
people who didn't believe in masks and
stuff and now they kind of like they
still don't like mass and they still
don't like falling like I remember
they're like oh they weren't lying like
I was really really sick like that
wasn't fun so it's I just be very
careful I think the thing that we all
have a tendency to do as humans is we
get emotional and then we choose like a
side and then like we agree with
everything on that side like oh
everything the government said must be a
lie because they lied once or someone
who worked for but the government isn't
like one thing it's like it's you and me
if we had jobs in government we'd be
government people and you and me might
not agree and one Department might be a
little bit corrupt and Shady or have
some agenda that they're not doing well
or trying to protect someone's
reputation or or drive a new story like
kind of stuff you don't want to hear
about the people in the government doing
but other another department might have
been like led by a really good person
for years who's really worried and cares
with all their heart about the health of
children and wants to make sure they
have access to good education and
nutrition or whatever and they've been
doing amazing work for decades so you
have to like break it down and realize
like it's not black versus white there's
a lot of gray in the world like the
person telling you not to trust the
government may have an agenda too they
may be trying to sell you something you
should be critical of everyone and think
for yourself and be an independent
thinker if you start to follow someone
with a platform an agenda that has a big
radio show or you know leads a
nutritional supplement company they may
have an agenda too to make you doubt
Pharmaceuticals like they may like all
pharmaceutical companies are not evil
like they are businesses and they do
need to like you know stay in business
but a lot of the people working there
are like I know people who are
virologists for years and some of the
smartest ones and got like recruited to
work at Pfizer and the the head of
Pfizer right now um and the Infectious
Disease area is a really good person who
trained with the very best structural
biologists who to solve the structure of
the protein on flu virus that lets it
get into cells and that guy's name is
Phil dormitzer and I've seen his work
and I've seen like at a conference they
had a vaccine against a virus I study
called CMV and it didn't work and he
presented the data and like we tried our
best this didn't work we're getting out
of this like we're not even gonna try to
do this anymore other companies can try
that's fine we've got our best shot this
platform's not working for us we have to
be honest about what the data is saying
we've been we've even tried it in like
Reese's macaques and we're just going to
be transparent and show the scientific
Community everything we did and even
though it didn't work and so you can
trust a guy like that when he shows you
data that does work yeah yeah okay last
question uh how do you feel about people
talking about
the role of diet vitamin D exercise
zinc whatever else and uh this is so
funny because it's true on the one hand
if you're malnourished your immune
system's not going to work as well
that's true
um however like when I grow a virus in
the lab and my grad students are
learning how to grow a virus prep like
you have to take care of yourselves and
like kind of like Manny them like
nurture them baby them because viruses
like healthy cells they require your
cells and the vitamins in your cells to
copy that they're pirating yourself they
love a healthy just like a person might
if you're a carnivore might like a juicy
steak like it's gonna make you feel
robust or if you're a vegan like have
like a really fresh macrobiotic bowl
like the virus getting into a well-fed
healthy person sells if it has all the
immune evasion tricks that that stars
Kobe do which is the virus that causes
Copa 19 does it hotwires the cell and
it's so stoked that you ate lots of
vitamin D and that you had a really
healthy diet and like yeah I mean zinc
may give you some tiny protection
against cold but once once the virus
gets in your cells this doesn't zinc is
not like a magical cure-all there's no
like super power that zinc gives you
it's it's a it's a micro it's a
micronutrient it's a it's a low
abundance like metal all it is important
as cofactor for certain enzymes but the
virus has enzymes that use utilize zinc
too to do these catalytic events to
escape your immune system so that's why
viruses often in history have been
harder to treat than bacteria because
they're using your cell circuits against
you they're they are a rogue genetic
code that mostly harnesses your own
Machinery they do have a few enzymes of
their own so if you're a well-fed
version and get a path if you're a
well-fed person and you catch Ebola or
you catch a really nasty flu virus or
coronavirus or loss of fever virus you
are no better off than for it like it's
not going to be like your your life is
safe from that your life is going to be
saved by having a good antibody
this is then this is the last question
why is it worse for people with multiple
problems or obesity and old people
that's a good question and they're still
they're still studying some of those
issues but like for instance diabetics
like have a really high amount of
unregulation dysregulation of blood
sugar so they get like their cat their
cert their vascular system is already
being kind of stressed and high pressure
high blood pressure is the same this
virus attacks the endothelial cells that
lie in your blood vessels and make and
makes like a dysregulated inflammatory
response so inflammation we know isn't
really healthy for us and these people
who have high blood pressure or diabetes
are already they're already existing in
a stress like even at Baseline before
they're sick their body is fighting just
to like maintain some level of Health
that they can function because some
things are kind of like not as healthy
as they could be about their like bodies
and so the virus just pushes it pushes
that further out of balance and that's
why they're probably at more risk of
severe disease but some of those
molecular mechanisms are still being
very much studied about why those people
get more sick but don't forget there are
people who don't have diabetes high
blood pressure who are like super good
athletes that we don't know yet why
certain ones get really really deathly
ill or even die and others don't what we
do know is that vaccines protect
everyone even diabetics even like those
weird people we don't understand why
they get sick
theoretically though if if eating less
sugar is eating less sugar reduce the
risk of diabetes
um it would reduce the risk of
developing certain types of diabetes
like Type 2 Diabetes Type 1 diabetes is
autoimmune so it's not going to help you
from that
so they're theoretically eating less
sugar which would is a component in in
certain diets
would reduce the risk of diabetes which
might decrease the risk of severe covid
yeah I mean being healthy is never a bad
thing but the the message that's being
put out there like hey if you lift a lot
of weights or work out a lot and have a
healthy diet you don't have to worry
about covid that is a mess and and the
Really irresponsible part of that is
you're amplifying like I am not so
worried about the average 20 year old
dying of covet I am worried about them
getting together spreading the virus
causing the emergence of new variants
that spread even better and then you
know people don't just hang out with
other 20 year olds they even if they
pretend they do they they have parents
they uh you know they work with other
people so the virus moves we've all seen
these graphs like the scientists
especially there's an outbreak among 20
year olds and 30 year olds and then
within six weeks there's that outbreak
has moved into the older age populations
who are trying to protect themselves but
you know grand grand Grandma still wants
to see your grandkids and the families
get together and I think that those are
the things we want to protect you want
to keep the schools open so why not
close the bars because people in bars
are talking without masks and being loud
and sucks have to close the bar but
maybe just have outdoor bars or
something or like you know figure out
how to like allow people to get together
outdoors in ways that are safe just like
talk about the facts and like make it so
like hey you want to go to a concert go
to an outdoor concert like let's try to
figure out or like let's how to work on
ventilation systems to like make it a
little bit safer but you know it's just
like let's just go with science and
reason based things that are like common
sense like you know I don't have to
argue with you about like a son the son
if you sit in the sun all day you can
get a sunburn like people believe that
they see it happen
um like we shouldn't have to have this
argument about viruses like that they
can be a threat agreed I agree okay I'm
out of time thank you so much for coming
on um if people want to find you is
there any way to find you yeah
um I'm on Twitter as macro leader which
is um it's like just a joke I did
because in in the lab you pipette micro
leaders which means a millionth of a
leader so um that's a place you can
follow me and then I'm Jeremy Camille
k-a-m-i-l
um and if you Google me and Mike Virus
you'll probably find uh some website
thanks for having me on and um luck and
stay healthy and get your own
information from reputable sources like
that don't believe people just check
check it out like like think for
yourselves it's a good thing to do have
fun oh great great thank you thank you
bye-bye bye
[Music]